hi I'm perfect I'm imperfect together
we're mediocrity no my real name is Ryan
right my real name's Dan cyber we're
gonna watch a trailer today for called
valiant hearts
I saw a previous one Dan told me that he
actually did see this one and he said
like the other one has a totally
different vibe and that I gotta check it
out most you guys know exactly what
trailer I'm talking about I later told
them after our previous valiant heart
was like you gotta watch this one
because this is like the one with like
the raw emotion of what the games about
because the other one just felt like
more of a cool action comic book kind of
ya know it kind of captured the action
axe aspect of it yeah this captures more
of what the tone I feel it's gonna be
okay cool yeah all right guys let's
watch this [ __ ] trailer let's do it
now I have to just remember how my
folders work trailers requested games
lotion is it launched No look at you let
me get those ones a minute or 42 longer
yeah just oh my I guess I got it I'll
check it I'll take it I'll take it I'll
check it out check it out check it yup
totally it totally it man eat well
reaction get that a little super boosts
told you man that she gets back e this
[ __ ] is also whack alright ready yeah
alright let's watch this
hello once again fantastic
to my dearest friends for the evil noise
of artillery tanks and planes
I remember our Avengers the friendship
and your pain my closest friend
Emil in your twilight years he came to
fight not for glory but to mend your
daughter's tears
lucky Freddie yeah you were always
fearless and with intent I hope you have
found peace with your letters that were
never send on my bravest of warriors
across the western front saving the
mountain of wounded without firing a
shot
and Carl only I could light our way home
through the fields of war through
treacherous nights to be with your
family once more although I cannot write
these words and the time has come to
part your stories will always remain as
will your valiant hearts
I don't think my face changed once
during its definition so much paying
attention to it please trailer reaction
oh my god it's such a big trailer I
think early on I was like I feel like I
want to cry but then I think with like
kind of [ __ ] up with my impact of that
trailer hmm might have been the fact
that I saw the previous one already yeah
kind of yeah because this was like the
introduction you know it have been like
wow you're getting me at a raw point you
know the one thing that the other
trailer I didn't really touch on but
yeah that dog is kind of like the key
connection connection yeah the thread
through all of these stories yeah and of
course it's just like whenever it's a
dog it's just so much more
heart-wrenching yes always that's up
your back I totally agree dogs are
[ __ ] tearjerkers Matt mm-hmm I want a
dog so bad oh man I want literal puppies
- I know
I want puppies that will make and then
give birth to other puppies and then I
could sell those puppies and make a
profit
I want a leader of litters of puppies
okay yeah okay yeah I want my puppy to
come to me from a virgin puppy so it
it's like you're holy jesus
okay the Jesus punished Jesus what's
really interesting to me about this game
is that it's based on true stories and
the fact - that like it's it seems like
it's a story-driven game no yeah
completely and I always dig a game like
that I feel like a lot of war games
really miss that opportunity yeah yeah
yeah and I feel like this is like one
that's like realizing like there's a
real story we could tell here you guys
yeah
so they make it look like kind of like a
comic book story you know it's clever I
think it's really clever [ __ ] smart
guys over there yeah smart guys a hoobie
are all right guys well thanks for
encouraging me kindly to watch this
trailer there were no threats at all
thank you
if you're new to the channel guys you
know you can do
subscribe and you know you could do for
Dan subscribe to dance gaming channel
yeah that that game did not have lift my
spirits at all sorry I'm getting
impressed with myself oh [ __ ] dude yeah
hey yeah he's been working out I haven't
been I've been starting a stuff in it
yeah that was two very different
sentences yeah that at the same time a
lot of you guys have been saying I'm fat
and that's why I've been working out to
show you guys I am improving mmm
people have been saying that I have a
beautiful face and thank you shoutout
time kadhi hot chair rude thanks for
that one you as the shiz and I hope you
continue to get work cool they please
have a shout-out if that's not too much
trouble
khadijah showed I know what it's like
being in the same tribe together my
friend we have to hunt together and it
was difficult and mothers would give
birth all the time and though we were we
had we knew usually right yeah oh and
you were from tribe to tribe together
yeah yeah okay just wanted to clarify
that before we moved on and there was
just so much hell we went through I'm
glad I I don't know what you're up to
but the fact that you have internet now
that's that's showing you're probably
out of the tribe now so good on you glad
you're making advances in your life I'm
in America now it's [ __ ] awesome
it's [ __ ] awesome greatest country on
the planet there's a lot of other
countries that watch it just right were
you from its I can't go in a detail the
country ah that they'll give it too much
away follow-up question were you hunter
or gatherer Oh hunter for sure okay did
you hunt McDonald's no definitely not
McDonald's ok Burger King then uh
sometimes we hunted for the restaurant
Burger King the epic journey to Burger
King be man four six six seven shout me
dot dot dot out Ryan Jenna me shout me
out
dr. dot
Ryan I think it should be shout out me
write or else I'm going to buy a whole
box of peeps and eat them in five
minutes with Sally next to me what is
what's the box of peeps what is one of
the most popular Easter treats of all
time peep the peep the little
marshmallow chickens coated and oh
that's what they're called
they're peeps oh because they could
maybe get your feet up but you know I'm
an um I'm not gonna show you out
I want you to actually send me a video a
five minute video of you eating a box of
peeps oh and if you can do that that
would be way [ __ ] cool
that'd be saying your name in a positive
manner I'm totally down I was I'll
subscribe to your channel yes if you do
I'll tell people subscribe yeah legit
shout me up before you go-go its
jitterbug hug its wake me up before you
go-go
don't leave me hanging on like a yo-yo
you don't want to talk I know you're
talking about I just I just don't want
to look like a [ __ ] homo on camera
damn it hey looks like straight people
can like wham - I've done a lot of
things on this channel that made me look
at no need to comment below and tell me
how how I'm so wrong about that
statement whitfill [ __ ] it up like a
guy's hair not like an emo enigma hey
Ryan can you a shoutout for me thanks
by the way I'm a Filipino hmm I'm a
Filipino that's I I'm a Filipino I'm
what you say it's not so weird I'm a
Filipino I'm a foot P no don't people
just go I'm Filipino
I'm Filipino I am a Filipino I
recommended it you but some of my
friends to watch your videos cuz it is
awesome dude thank you so much for doing
that really letting the Filipino
community know that there is a half
Filipino man
there who is making you guys proud
because I I talk about a lot of relevant
things in the Filipino community yeah
there's a lack of dick jokes there's a
lack of vagina talk okay there's a lack
of consistently pursuing women when you
know they're gonna say no to you okay
and there's a lack of trailers too they
don't show a lot of trailers in the
Philippines it's mainly just sometimes a
movie or two mmm I figured out the
country of origin the tribe was their
tribes in the Philippines yes ah
connection call me Sherlock Holmes [ __ ]
here Sherlock Holmes I'm your [ __ ] oh
well then this is my channel now okay
wherever you want that you're a lot more
submissive than I thought you'd be
Filipinos are not that you know will
understand that's not true we got with
Manny Pacquiao so pretty sure I just get
punched in the face away everything that
Filipinos like if they're not getting
their way they'll [ __ ] let you know
if you're like a stranger and then we
seen karaoke together it's awesome annex
karaoke I'm gonna be performing rap God
really yeah
oh man I'll be there that'd be I'm gonna
do it I'll bring camera number one
record it
yeah we're posted on channels yeah I'll
check all channel all the channels yeah
everyone's gonna get a chance well
upload the video give you a link to
download it and upload on to your
channel please say Aye send up a check